so chris we were talking going into the
break about stupid stuff i have done and
i have done a lot of stupid stuff
we used to do a theme hour here on the
air where people would call in and tell
stories
of stupid things that they did that cost
them money when i lose money to doing
something stupid i call it stupid tax
as you know yes and uh so you pay stupid
tax when you do something stupid and you
lose money as a result and i try not to
pay the same stupid tax twice
meaning don't do the same stupid stuff
there's plenty other stupid stuff to do
that's right
why repeat one so
but here's what we've discovered over
the years there are
uh classes of people
lower class middle class upper class on
the socioeconomic ladder
okay and there's different stupid stuff
among age groups and among classes of
people
for instance you don't see
the payday lender the car
title pawn in the rich end of town
that's always in the poor into town
right uh you don't se
and so that's the stupid stuff and the
tote the note lot right
okay and that kind of stuff and and
then the upper class does other kind of
stupid stuff most of theirs is prestige
oriented
they're trying to buy recognition with a
stupid purchase to be somebody they're
not or something like that
they're trying to get fulfillment in the
wrong place the middle class
it pretty well falls into four or five
categories i mean
uh they don't usually middle class
doesn't do a payday lender right they're
not going to fall for that and they
don't buy a lot of lottery tickets
most of the lottery tickets are sold in
lower income zip codes
the middle class it's obviously credit
cards
it's car leases fleeces we call them
it's whole life life insurance it's uh
time shares yep timeshares
are getting to be hey i'm seeing them
more i mean i thought that would have
died off by now because it's
because it's stupid on steroids well it
really is i mean they're expensive
and they have absolutely no value it's
one of the few products out there that
you can find a 93
dissatisfaction level with like
everybody that buys it
wishes they didn't yes and yet people
keep buying them yeah
dave we got 9.6 million households have
one or more
shares 9.6 million good lord uh 64
are married and the average age of a
timeshare owner is 44 years old so it's
that
at that bracket you're talking about
yeah so it's a middle-aged stupid
it is it really is but it sounds
sophisticated it doesn't sound
sophisticated well
at the all to go to a hotel room
which you could have rented there's
nothing sophisticated about this at all
all it was was you went on a free
vacation
and got put in a room oh yeah and they
wouldn't let you out of the room for
seven hours
and you couldn't say no so you said yes
you got screwed and you paid 14 to 25
000 bucks for air you don't have an
asset
and you can't resell it because nobody
wants it well they say
that it's deeded well yeah some are and
some aren't right but
even if it's deeded what do you got you
got to deed the air some people
nobody you're going to sit nobody wants
your weak
look on ebay look on craigslist they're
everywhere
you can't give the dadgum things away
you are stuck
yeah oh well i've got points just same
stupid thing they say about a credit
card say about the credit cards you got
to try using that for your credit card
use that for you
you have a sense of ownership i love
that you have a sense of ownership
that's in the pitch
yeah when you're the pitch it's kind of
like being an owner except you're not
oh my restrictions so many restrictions
and and then the point system it it
requires a trigonometry degree to figure
out
all the nuances let me tell you how
you'll never go on vacation
all right okay you use your airline
miles and try to book your air
and line it up with your week that you
bought points on on the timeshare
these two things are never in the same
freaking
aquarius would have to be aligned i mean
mars i have to be aligned with venus
to get all this to line up the chances
of you getting
this middle-class free crap you thought
you were going to get
ever lined up is zero yeah
well so let me try again don't buy time
shirts be clear dave don't buy time i
don't want to be unclear
i know it's a long and aggressive sales
presentation so i have to match
the length and the aggression to offset
it i think there's a
thing here no don't buy time shares and
not to mention
the preying on people that want better
than they have
feel like they're entitled to some stuff
and
they they play up to that mental sense
of you being smart to do this
let me help you yeah if you're gonna pay
17 to five thousand dollars for
something
okay just take that and divide a hotel
room into it
and you can go anywhere in the freaking
world you wanna go and sleep and you
don't have a thousand dollar maintenance
fee that goes up every year that's true
and you aren't stuck and frustrated
and then the property gets tired meaning
warn the freak out by the freaks who
went on your week the other weeks
into your unit this is not the way to
enjoy your
vacation it sounds sophisticated it
sounds high-end
it's just not and uh don't don't fall
for it
matter of fact don't even go to the
meeting please yeah don't even go
because i'm gonna tell you it won't let
you out yeah you don't have to you have
to draw a firearm to be released
like clint eastwood yeah i'm all over
here i'm out of here
but seriously just don't go and uh this
is one of those things where
if you know this about yourself i have
trouble saying no
don't never go into a meeting where the
only way you're going to get out there
is saying yes
yeah no and you know the only way you
can do that is you've got to deal with a
reputable company
uh to be able to walk through the
process and it's still going to cost
money
yeah they're really money to get in
costs money to get out there's just no
fun in this discussion no
it is not fun listen i have i have
coached and counseled families for 30
years the number of times i found
someone who loved
their time share is almost zero
now if you're out there and you love
your timeshare you should really think
about that but
um i'm happy for you you're one of the
four or five or six
or seven percent of the people who
actually are satisfied with
one of the worst financial products on
the planet have i been unclear it's
right up there with payday lender it's
the payday lender of the middle class
the whole life life insurance
the car fleece the credit card airline
miles
these are dumb things that people lose
money on called stupid tax
and let me just the people in the
business
are scummy yeah
even big name companies like marriott
and people like that get it they're
scummy
they're scummy it's just it's how it
works you know
and the time shares people it's like ugh
and you ask we've had people call in
here that used to work for the business
and they're like
i'm going to end up doing a documentary
on this one of these days because
the the people behind the scenes that
want to come forward and expose
what is going on in that business what
happens in the sales presentation well
we'll take it back no they won't
i won't they lied they will not take it
back no they will not
and so you could wait three days to
think i can just call back they won't
they really won't
uh they'll pull up camp and they're
moved on to the next individual
so yeah they just they're the next herd
of cattle that they can put in a room
and butcher
that's right it's just
just hurt them in there and shoot them
it's just oh my gosh
that's what happens to you man so please
please please please do not
fall for this if you want to go on
vacation i want you to go on vacation
sharon and i've traveled all over the
world it's been one of the dreams of our
life to build some wealth and enjoy
some of our time and get to see some of
the coolest places in the world
but you know the number of times that
that you want to go back to the same
exact
place over and over and over and over
again
it's very rare it's extremely rare it's
free yeah don't put yourself
in don't give yourself don't do that at
least buy a condo right you know save up
your money buy you a beach condo if you
want to be in the beach buy you a condo
at the mountains if you want to be in
the mountains i don't care but at least
by god you'll own
something then that could go up in value
that somebody could actually buy
and you could turn around and resell it
you could resell it and this though
you are just stuck yeah it's air
timeshare is greek for
i'm stuck i can't get out and my money
is gone
i can't get out let me go
they won't do it you're stuck they got
you
stupid tax timeshares
on the list this is the dave ramsey show